From Goth to rainbow, via the
grisliest crimes the U.S. Navy
has ever faced — who else but NCIS' Abby Sciuto?
Abby Sciuto's style, as seen on
NCIS from Season 1 to Season 15,
often seems to clash with her chipper
personality, but this forensic scientist
is ultimately a goth at heart. After all, Abby
loves not just death, but the supernatural,
tattoos, and black clothes and jewelry,
too. Maybe that's why Abby became a fan
favorite in short order — it's certainly what
the minds behind the character were aiming for.
Part of executive producer Donald
Bellisario's intent with Abby was
to create a positive depiction of a person
with tattoos and piercings. Perrette told CBS:
She also discussed how many girls
followed in her character's footsteps,
taking up math and science courses in
college because Abby made these topics fun.
Outside of work, Abby is a competent, plucky,
and kind-hearted human being. And part of her
now-iconic ensemble is her striking black hair,
which she typically fashions into
pigtails with bangs. Interestingly,
though, that hair color isn't the shade
that actor Pauley Perrette was born with.
Over the years, Pauley Perrette's jet black
locks may have become one of the trademarks
of Abby Sciuto on NCIS, but the actor's hair is
actually blonde. To pull off her look as Abby,
Perrette regularly dyed it black with
the help of hair and make-up assistants,
who also gave her a hand applying
Abby's neck tattoo before filming
began each day. She once told CBS Sunday
Morning that, while working on the series,
she actually ended up with dyed roots.
Furthermore, the actor tweeted in 2013:
However, Perrette revealed on The Queen
Latifah Show that this has actually led
to some health complications. She developed
a PPD allergy, a condition that can happen
when you've been dyeing your hair black
for a long time. During filming on NCIS,
she woke up with her head swelling
and had to be rushed to the hospital.
"By the time I got to the hospital, half
my head was this big and the other half
was this big, and my eyes were swollen shut,
and I'm like, 'people need to see this.'"
Afterward, the actor only used black hairspray,
right up until she left
NCIS during its 15th season.
Evidently, dyeing her hair black wasn't
the best move for Pauley Perrette,
but that's not to say that dyeing her hair
other colors is out of the question. With
NCIS — and Abby Sciuto — behind her, she
made the bold choice in 2021 to try out
a brand new look. Instead of choosing just
one hair color, though, she chose multiple,
revealing a vibrant rainbow hairstyle in
November of that year. In a Twitter post that
showed off her new, colorful appearance
for the world to see, Perette wrote:
In the time since debuting this bright hairdo,
she seems to have kept up with it, as her hair
has remained that way in a number of subsequent
social media posts. With that, it doesn't look
like she has any intention of returning to life
as Abby on NCIS any time soon. And, between her
serious PPD allergy and the tricky nature of the
fame that came with the show, who could blame her?
Yes, it seems that Pauley Perrette is doing
just fine away from NCIS and the Abby Sciuto
role. Maybe someday she'll give both of
them another go, but for the time being,
she seems to be enjoying the freedom to do
whatever she'd like — including with her hair.